para este jueves está convocado a una
gran marcha nacional contra el
presidente y uno de sus asesores en
reconocí que ministros que han puesto su
cargo a disposición del mandatario es
este el momento más crítico de pedro
castillo desde que llegó al poder
buenas noches señor golpear es un gusto
si efectivamente este debe ser el
momento más crítico para el presidente
castillo por un lado porque son las
movilizaciones más grandes a las que se
está enfrentando hasta ahora había
habido movilizaciones incluso desde los
primeros días de su gestión pidiendo su
salida pero mucho más ideologizada de
determinados sectores de la derecha este
son los movimientos más grandes y además
esto tiene que tener en consideración
que varias de las regiones están
movilizadas ya estamos hablando de 15
por lo menos de las 25 regiones del país
son regiones en las que el presidente
castillo tuvo alto nivel de votación de
hecho la región de la que es originaria
su para el partido político por el que
gobierna es una de las naciones donde se
ha puesto el foco del conflicto y donde
hay al menos tres de los fallecidos
nosotros estamos hablando de la pérdida
de legitimidad de un presidente que se
hizo llamar desde el inicio el
presidente del pueblo y del gobierno del
pueblo y que parece haber perdido a ese
pueblo del todo
a ver ustedes precisamente de una carga
ideológica en estas protestas se puede
decir de que hay una excusa para
intentar sacar a castilla del cargo
en un conjunto de los actores políticos
quizás quienes están más cercanos al
parlamento hay una búsqueda de razones
de excusas efectivamente que vienen
desde el inicio el presidente castillo
ya ha enfrentado en estos ocho meses dos
intentos de vacancia presidencial
dirigidos por esos partidos políticos
pero esos partidos políticos están
siendo rechazados también por quienes se
manifiestan parte de estas
movilizaciones y parte de lo que las
encuestas nos muestran que quiere la
ciudadanía no es sólo el cambio en torno
a las políticas que está ejerciendo el
presidente castillo e incluso la salida
de presidente castillo sino que se habla
de que se vayan todos es decir que
vayamos a unas nuevas elecciones tanto
presidenciales como regionales es por
allí donde está el rechazo si bien se
dirige al ser presidente castillo porque
había una promesa de cambio y luego de
ocho meses la ciudadanía siente que no
se han cumplido con esos cambios
prometidos también hay un rechazo
general a los partidos políticos y el
quehacer del parlamento
por qué y qué es haciendo uno de los
epicentros de esas marchas y también de
los enfrentamientos tiene eso que ver
con lo que usted nos comentaba antes de
que estas protestas ocurren en regiones
que votaron por pedro castillo y que
ahora se sienten traicionadas
en el caso de vita tiene que ver con que
efectivamente hay un importante número
de transportistas y personalidades
agrarias más importantes y por tanto el
costo del transporte pero el costo
también ellos llevan ya varios años
reclamando cambios en torno a las
normativas agrarias hace dos años
tuvimos una protesta en la zona que dejó
cerca de 4 fallecidos también es una
zona donde hay o donde se estarían
movilizando intereses también
partidarios de la oposición al
presidente castillo y si además una
región donde habiendo la gran
expectativa en determinado momento de
este gobierno pudiese por ejemplo hacer
esos ajustes pues ajustes en las
normativas agrarias no se han dado esto
sumado a huancayo y algunas gestiones
oriente del país estarían siendo por los
puntos en los que el presidente castillo
tendría que esperar su atención en los
próximos días